will be  neither policy nor principle  no one is different no one  is not true if superman were here  what would you want to say to him that  my family too had dreams  to look him in his eye and ask him how  he decides  which lives count and which ones do not  there's a new kind of mean in him  he is angry and he's hunting  i didn't kill those men if that's what  they think  this is what makes you such a good  reporter stuff like this still shocks  you  i'm older now than my father ever was  this may be the only thing i do that  matters  so fools the hearts of wayne  and the world only makes sense if you  that dream is all some people have it's  all that gives them hope now god  is good as dead  men made a world where standing together  is impossible  we will we have to  you